also today more resorts announcing their
plans to reopen here in Las Vegas very
important here the key date is June 4th
you're gonna hear it a lot now this
morning Caesars Entertainment said it
would open Caesars Palace and the
Flamingo first stores and restaurants at
the Linc promenade are also going to be
available as well as the high roller
again June 4th
both resorts will offer the hotel dining
gaming and pool access Caesars expects
Harrah's and the link which it also owns
will be the next to reopen both the wind
and the encore will also open on June
4th and that includes the casinos in the
sports books some restaurants there are
gonna open a little bit earlier but
extensive safety measures are in place
guests will have their temperature taken
as they walk on-site MGM Resorts just
announced that it is opening three of
its Las Vegas properties June 4th the
Bellagio New York New York and the MGM
Grand will start serving customers with
similar safety guidelines in places the
rest of the properties in town the
signature hotel attached to the MGM
Grand is also going to be open the
company plans to open more strip resorts
as demand increases